bonsoir thomas alors depuis plusieurs
jours déjà le congrès américain est à
pied d'oeuvre pour valider les décisions
de joe biden oui depuis son investiture
joe biden est toujours dans cette
volonté de ne pas perdre de temps et il
sait que les 100 premiers jours d'un
mandat présidentiel aux états unis sont
décisifs le congrès se penche en ce
moment sur différentes nominations
proposées par l'administration maiden
pour des postes importants dans les
domaines tels que la sécurité ou encore
le domaine militaire
joe biden espérer une sorte d' unité
transpartisane pour ces mesures
concernant la lutte contre la pandémie
de kobe 19 ou encore le plan de relance
de l'économie américaine
mais les divisions subsistent au congrès
ralentissant la feuille de route du
nouveau président il faut dire que les
annonces ces derniers jours de la maison
blanche concernant le climat et
l'immigration notamment ont rapidement
fait apparaître le clivage entre les
démocrates et les républicains légende à
charge et thomas surtout que la page
donald trump n'est pas complètement
tourné la chambre des représentants doit
déposer justement ce lundi au sénat une
mise en accusation de l'ancien président
pour une deuxième procédure d'
impeachment
oui le camp démocrate a fait savoir
qu'il voulait aller vite sur ce dossier
il estime avoir suffisamment de charges
contre donald trump et son incitation
supposée à l'insurrection lors des
événements du capitole le 6 janvier
dernier à washington il faut depuis ce
moment donald trump se fait plutôt
discret le procès s'ouvrira le 8 février
on n'entend pas vraiment donald trump il
faut dire que son moyen de communication
préféré twitter et bien à banny son
compte c'est donc ici en floride que
réside désormais l'ancien locataire de
la maison blanche
nous sommes allés dans le sud de cet
état à la rencontre des supporters de
l'ancien président donald trump au plus
près de son nouveau lieu de villégiature
c'est un reportage réalisé avec lucas tu
as et je vous demanderais d'être
attentif il se peut que vous aperceviez
justement donald trump dans ce reportage
14h30 sur cette route de palm beach
une dizaine de supporters donald trump
dé rassembler quand soudain une escorte
arrive à bord de cette voiture donald
trump qui adressent des signes en
direction de ses soutiens
le tout devant notre caméra pourquoi on
est là parce qu'on pense qu'il a gagné
c'est pour ça qu'on est là parce qu'on
pense qu'il devrait encore être notre
président je viens de l'autre bout de la
floride
j'ai conduit jusqu'ici pour voir ce qui
se passe et le voir rentrer chez lui
depuis qu'il a quitté la maison blanche
le 20 janvier dernier donald trump vie
ici dans sa résidence de marc à la
gauche dans l'état de floride un état
qui lui est restée fidèle
lors de la dernière élection de 2020 en
lui et réa corps dans une majorité c'est
depuis cette résidence sous le soleil de
la floride que donald trump pourrait
élaborer ces plans pour un éventuel
retour en politique il se dit par
exemple que donald trump pourrait lancer
son propre parti et pourquoi pas
concourir pour la présidentielle de 2000
24 il faudra pour cela contourner
l'obstacle impeachment mais selon ses
soutiens ici à palm beach
l'avenir de donald trump en politique
est loin d'être terminée
dans le quartier huppé de west palm
beach l'emménagement de donald trump
divise delà des clivages politiques
certains se plaignent de l'impact
logistique de l'arrivée d'un ancien
président près de chez eux
ce n'est pas le cas de mairie depuis
chez elle cette fervente et lectrices
républicaine a une vue imprenable sur la
résidence de mara là il était mon voisin
avant d'être mon président et je suis
contente qu'ils soient revenus ici il
pourra au moins se reposer j'espère et
réfléchir à la suite et nax pas certaine
que donald trump songe réellement à se
présenter à nouveau à une élection
présidentielle mais oui ne crois pas en
tout cas que la procédure d' impeachment
puisse aboutir
gymglish min je vois pas ce qu'ils
veulent l'empêcher de faire ils ont
essayé avec la sphère de la russie c'est
vraiment ce qui m'a poussé à le soutenir
j'ai suivi attentivement les auditions
dans cette affaire de collusion avec la
russie et il n'y avait rien je vote pour
quiconque aime ce pays
mais s'il se présente à nouveau je le
soutiendrai à coup sûr car je sais qu'il
aime ce pays un soutien indéfectible à
donald trump que mary partage avec son
groupe d'amis parmi elles il y à cherry
sans aucun doute la plus démonstrative
elle nous présente ce véhicule
entièrement customisé à la gloire de
l'ancien président le fils de donald
trump a signé il si le jour de la fête
du travail
sa famille et lui étaient en voiture et
ils m'ont vu et ils m'ont interpellé en
me disant qu'ils adorent et mon véhicule
dernier ajout sur son véhicule ce
t-shirt concernant linux mint ça venait
pas
3 vous ne pouvez pas effacer plus de 75
millions de votes légaux je pense qu'en
fait il pourrait même être encore plus
efficace dans le secteur privé pour sa
base il est un porte-parole
on lui a donné notre voix on ne le
trahira pas notre président notre porte
voix il a délivré de notre message ce
n'est pas son message c'est le nôtre et
il le transmet très critique contre le
camp démocrate
cherry continue d'afficher fièrement son
soutien à donald trump
malgré l'investiture de joe biden elle
continuera de suivre la voie choisie par
donald trump qu'elle considère encore
comme son président
[Musique]
devant thomas bonnet vous entendez pas
en tournée avec lucas tu as ici en
floride
oui pardon juste voilà support reportage
qu'on a tourné avec lucas tu as ici en
floride il faut noter donc il ya encore
des supporters de donald trump vous
l'avez vu parfois très motivé mais
certains nous expliquer quand même que
l'atmosphère était un petit peu retombée
depuis l'investiture de joe biden et que
le plus dur reste à venir maintenant
pour ceux qui espèrent peut-être un
retour de l'ancien président merci
thomas bonnin en direct donc depuis
orlando aux états unis merci à vous